there's a pattern here isn't there
almost every website follow some type of
grid structure but where's the grid
structure coming from as it turns out
CSS allows us to control how wide our
elements are and how they're arranged on
the page but this should be a pretty
easy task right once we know what kind
of grid we want we should pretty easily
be able to just snap elements to the
right points in the grid looking back at
the Udacity courses page we've got all
of these classes listed on the right
side of the screen we've got options for
making sure that they all fit within
this column on the right either
we can go into each class here and style
its HTML and CSS individually to make
sure that they all fit on the right side
of the screen or we could create some
kind of general CSS classes that define
the styles that we need to keep all the
courses in the right column in fact
creating CSS classes that control layout
is considered a best practice today and
we call these sets of classes frameworks
let's dive deeper into what frameworks
need to do